we wanted to see the movies from his
eyes and from his point of view just so
we can track that this movie isn't just
about a bratty kid trying to escape her
parents it's also about a parent trying
to reconnect with his daughter
hi i'm mike miranda i'm the writer and
director of the mitchell's versus the
machines i am christopher miller i'm one
of the producers i can confirm all of
this and i am phil lord i'm also one of
the producers
[Music]
rick the dad and katie his daughters
sort of have a hard time connecting
throughout the movie and that is sort of
what the movie is about is them trying
to find this connection that they used
to have we wanted to make this scene as
sort of like a stand-in for every parent
who sort of when their kids are young
you sort of idealize that time but also
it's a more innocent time and it's a
less complicated time and sort of now
things are a little more contentious and
he's trying to sort of figure out how to
get that back yeah the scene before this
has
katie and her father getting into an
argument that he doesn't understand why
she wants to go to film school and what
her whole passion is about
i think it's really interesting that
he's watching home movies yeah and using
the power of cinema to remember the past
yeah and the very camera that she fell
in love with is the thing he's watching
these movies on it was a really bold
choice to have the scene be so dark it's
a thing that you don't see in animation
very often where people want everything
to be bright and colorful and incredibly
vibrant in every moment in a way that's
very unrealistic have unlimited lights
and you can put it anywhere so people do
so it's very difficult to remind
yourselves that oh maybe this is only
going to be lit by the television screen
we wanted to make the room he's in as
cool as possible to make it feel like
this is what he's going through
emotionally and he's looking back at
these sort of rose-tinted memories of
what sort of he's missing out on one of
the things i really think is cool about
this thing is it really showcases some
of the real bold choices you made with
the animation and illustrative style
mike wanted to look like you're inside
of a watercolor illustration we were
really inspired by a woman named lindsay
laveras whose art mike had found on the
internet and then we hired her as the
production designer and he was like i
wish the movie could just feel like one
of her drawings her personal aesthetic
became the aesthetic of this movie that
felt incredibly handmade and felt like
nothing that's ever been done in
animation before like katie's sketchbook
come to life exactly these characters
they have painted outlines and
watercolor textures on them and figuring
out how to get them to blend in with
this very naturalistic painted
environment was a real challenge if you
look at the trees you can see how each
of those trees is a cg tree but it looks
very convincingly like a hand painted
watercolor tree the grass you can see
that it is it looks like it's a wash
with little painted lines in it but
actually is geometrically grass well and
just like rick is coming from the past
and katie is coming from the future we
had to negotiate how to
make a art style that's as old as time
drawing and sort of how can we get that
on a modern computer and how can we like
teach a computer to draw like a person
well i teach a computer to draw like a
17 year old like film student the danger
of these incredibly powerful tools is
that they
make all the movies look the same we're
not trying to make something that feels
formulaic it felt like you could see all
the imperfections of the family in every
frame of the movie we love those
imperfections that's sort of what makes
us great
[Applause]
[Music]
i really love the music in the scene
mark mothersbot we had a lot of
conversations in the beginning and
there's this uh really sweet sort of
cooing sound that mark made with um some
sort of bizarre electronic device but it
is sort of like the stand-in for katie
whenever you see katie you're hearing
these soft like digitized voice coupes
and i found the sweetest synthesizer of
all yes like a sweet little computer
that was like i'm the loneliest computer
in the warehouse i find it really
interesting that like the most intimate
most human humane piece of the score
is generated electronically like that
top that's holding the melody i think is
like a synthesized voice
this is like
your favorite thing
well it's yours now
see this little guy is scared to be
alone so you're gonna have to cheer him
up for me okay
and i remember we tried to get actual
human beings yeah to sing it and it lost
everything well and it's and it's a way
to combine the two sort of worlds of the
movie and i think he does it really
nicely where these two things can work
together to meld analog yeah and
technology
[Music]
well
i guess this is it
oh yep it's a very bittersweet moment
where it's the life is full of
possibility but it's sort of the end of
a really close emotional era for your
family what's sweet about this
scene is that they really do get to
express how much they love each other
[Music]
[Laughter]
the one thing that really sort of like i
felt opened the scene up is we started
adding these little flourishes that sort
of reflect katie's point of view we call
them katie vision so she's so excited
about college so you see rainbows above
the college and you see sort of like
her emotions through these little
doodles and it was really nice because
it made me feel closer to her as a
character and it also felt like if she
was editing the movie herself she would
have added these things
so you know
when i'm sad to be alone
i'll always have
my favorite thing
they have this talisman that mike you
and jeff and your team came up with of
this little moose that he made so we
just wanted something that pulled back
to the fact that rick at one point was
also an artist it was something that
came from this
cabin that he built with his bare hands
that he's really proud of and even
though he's sort of like forgotten about
that part of his life his daughter's
just entering the part of her life where
she's engaging with that stuff and
really falling in love with it
come here
[Music]
mom you're hugging too tight you love it
you love it
i do love it
this moment where she decides she wants
to keep it always gets me choked up
they're ending the movie in a much
better place as a family than they were
at the beginning of the film
he starts the movie looking backwards
yeah and then he ends it looking
forwards
[Music]